I understand like the thought process
I'm just I looked this up beside a
different corn star on my show and I
didn't believe it and then I went and
the study was either from Utah or
California I can't remember which but
they took Coinstars versus non-coin
stars and Coinstars had a higher STD
rate I mean listen even if you are in
the foreign industry like my body counts
not very high for the amount of work
that I've done my body count was pretty
low beforehand
um I just think we're a lot safer
because I've slept with men that were in
the industry and they don't care either
to wrap up or to go get tested and I
make sure not obviously proceed with
those people but they just don't care
and neither do some of the women